today's topic Kanye Kyrie and the Jews
Hey listen we walking on a thin ice you
feel me because how every [ __ ] black
artist has been talking about this issue
to be like hey yeah you know yeah yeah
yeah
we don't support or condone that kind of
time but these are my yeah
so why don't we cut through the [ __ ]
and let's talk about it I'd ask you
first how do you feel you're gonna wear
Kanye West Kyrie Irving I have been
reprimanded either by big companies like
Adidas that have cut their ties with
Kanye or the Brooklyn Nets who suspended
Kyrie Irving the basketball player and
told him he had a bunch of Demands
including sensitivity training before
you can come back to work over the fact
that he endorsed or kind of highlighted
a documentary or a movie of sorts that
was on Amazon he was trying to tell
people to go watch it and that
documentary is a little bit spicy you
know alluded to some anti-semitic stuff
some some mustache man thing it was kind
of crazy
allegedly so you're going to go after
Kyrie for having like just retweeting
the the link to that documentary which
is not going to go after Jeff Bezos for
having that on his platform was it the
money what's what's going on huh hold on
I asked him a question
huh
you're not gonna go after the actual
platform that this thing is on that
you're against you're gonna go after the
player huh
not speak up I didn't hear yeah nothing
the six things that you have to do to go
back to I think that's a bit much
that's me that's a bit much
that's a bit much the second thing if I
talk about Kanye whatever Kanye whether
you like Kanye or not who you think is a
[ __ ] or whatever would I
um I'm gonna say this you Adidas you
severaged your ties with Kanye but
you're still gonna sell the Yeezys
I am not having none of it none
it's all about the money
so are you saying you got money but
you're not buying I I got I got the
money
it's right there
not buying the inconsistency
is that sequence
but it's it's crazy but when they said
that oh yeah no we're still gonna uh
yeah we don't we do not agree with but
we still gonna sell the price God damn
from my perspective
seeing the media and these organizations
reprimand Kyrie or Kanye I suspect that
this didn't lower
anti-Semitism in any type of way if
anything it just fermented it and
increased it in the lives
you have to get at the root of it which
is a lot of people kind of Parry to this
Trope that Jewish people are part of
some kind of grand conspiracy or that
they have all the power and then moment
this kind of stuff is brought up
everyone says anti-semitic and they try
to Lobby some kind of criticism or try
to get these people to pay for the
things that they've said
even Dave Chappelle recently
in his monologue people have come at him
for saying he's normalizing ain't Tyson
I remember one point during this whole
thing Dave talks about the fact that he
worked in Hollywood for a long time and
he's like
there's a lot of Jews in Hollywood
and people are like oh my God here
here's the thing you getting on your
account and you're like oh I said
guess what
if you've ever worked in Hollywood
there's a lot of Jews
whether you like it or not and if our
response to that statement is inherently
just get this person get rid of this
person you know what the average person
is looking at that thing and thinking
do they say a lie because if they didn't
why are you trying to cancel them or
trying to get them reprimanded so
instead of always turning to immediately
just being like oh anti-semite oh why
don't you do the smart thing which is
just demystify the reasons why Jewish
folks may be rep over represented in
positions of leadership in Hollywood or
demystify the reason why Biden's cabinet
is like 50 Jewish like even though these
are such a small population only time we
see them represented in media is when
they're at the upper echelons of society
that's generally how we internalize
Jewish people the thing I'm I'm trying
to get at is
as a black person the only time we ever
heard about Jewish people was either
like when they were running some company
or when they were referencing rap songs
or hip-hop music videos if you're
walking through the street you meet a
Jewish person you might not even know
they're Jewish because they just
represent as white presenting the only
time you really internalize someone's
juice is when you hear about them
achieving things right it's like it's
not like Asians I see Asians at my
corner store I see them in the streets
they're visible they're on the buses
with me I don't know when I'm next to a
Jews person so my only media
interpretation of Jewish people is in
positions of power or in rap songs being
spoken about very poorly get me and as
someone who's
digested hip-hop all I ever heard since
the 90s is like these [ __ ] are
stealing her money these [ __ ] are
doing that the Jewish people control us
right that is all I ever heard and then
I looked and I got buying this cabinet
that's 50 good that's all you're seeing
from a media perspective so that's where
folks have to come in and demystify the
reason why because right now I don't
know why because if you don't we're
still going to see what it is we just
won't know why it's there you get what
I'm trying to say and to just draw a
quick parallel black people are over
represented when it comes to crime in
North America
if you almost says yo black people
commit a lot of crime and you're
response you gotta do the extra step and
be like the reason why they're so
overrepresented is due to cultural
socio-economic issues poverty then you
demystify so you understand okay once
you remove a lot of these factors
actually the crime rate dropped
significantly until the point where it's
like not that different from here's
something that is true okay and I
actually linked to somebody who really
studied Jewish history and was a scholar
such and they talk about the fact that
during the 50s and 60s the people who
are either the co-owners or owners of a
lot of the record labels okay we're
Jewish people and these were people who
were assigned these people to
exploitative deals where they're either
stealing their money stealing a lot of
the cuts of their artists and basically
going through the process where they
were taking advantage of black people in
these positions now if you understand
the history of black folks in North
America there's a lot of exploitation
where they feel a lot of the wealth that
black people generated has been siphoned
out of the community and when you
constantly see media representation of
Jewish people and stealing those as well
as historical context that makes that
[ __ ] true
you can understand why there's a bit of
a negative sentiment in animosity like
this might surprise y'all but most black
people did not give a [ __ ] about Kanye's
comments about Jewish people they didn't
really care about what Kyrie did because
their relationship with the Jewish
people was like oh yeah it actually
sound true
so until you demystify that most likers
are not gonna care
and then you punish these people whether
you feel that's Justified or not
they're just gonna build that animosity
even further so this is why I'm trying
to say the dialogue needs to be a bit
better we're talking about the music and
Jewish people and it's crazy
there's a bunch of bars
I remember when I like
um I was listening to Fuji's you know
the fujis was big for me right because
that's the first time I saw some Asian
people being well represented and being
proud to be Haitian and stuff like that
going before that era it was not good to
to to to be uh to be black or to be like
Haitian even like whatever
um
hahaha
and I remembered I used to be underrated
now I take Heinz make my [ __ ]
constipated I'm more concentrated so on
my day off with David's son and Berg I
play golf everything is a reference to a
CEO of Sony and this and that
once upon apps coming up mazel tov from
one who met before I'm black I'm first
human I protect the right like Frederick
Douglass went to sleep like it was
always if you listen to hip-hop
there's always a reference yep and
saying well there's a lot it's it's you
there's a lot of Jews in there's a lot
of juice there's a lot of there's a lot
of black people in a lot of Industries
right
there's a lot of people in in rap that's
racist okay there's a lot of people in
the NFL that's racist there's a lot of
black people in rocket none of this is
racist and what's good we could say that
but we talk about white people though
though we could say well white people
listening why people are in a position
of power yeah
that's bad
but but
the other represent over representation
we can't really talk about
and then when we do because we want a
question we just want a question
we can't do that it's just it's it's not
you have to understand how weird it
sounds guys
is that true though what that they just
want a question
because if we being honest let me let me
put on my little you know I mean
if I'm being honest a lot of people are
not just being locked well I'm quite
some of them being like yo listen bro
how you feel about the Illuminati
because the Jews run this [ __ ] yeah I
heard that thing as well yeah yeah I
know you like it a lot but you going
back to like and kosher too [ __ ]
yeah you about to get it I understand I
understand that but it's like we can't
even there's no
there's no
you can't maneuver this thing
you can't maneuver or ask because you're
always walking on eggshells that's us
whether you want a question or you're
like uh
the minute you talk about something then
you get X
that's weird
and you don't know how they say like hey
if if you want to know who's oppressing
you just
check who you can't talk about
man we can't talk about y'all
like you talk about us
we can't
not even state of fact
we're gonna be classified that's it's us
are you trying to say you feel oppressed
by the Jews nope
not me yeah I I don't um
I don't have that deep of a curiosity
about these uh this group of people I
don't uh it's not something I really
research or take it interesting I'm just
telling you what I've heard through my
peripheries pretty much my entire life
growing up and so that's why I wasn't
surprised buying these comments because
this sounds like a lot of the [ __ ] I was
hearing in hip-hop pretty much my whole
life yeah
um and so yeah my suggestion is just
that when it comes to this conversation
because you're looking at two
communities that are coming from a place
of like damage and extreme hurt right
you have the Jewish people dealing with
their Holocaust and you know
anti-Semitism throughout the world they
got black folks who are dealing with you
know Jim Crow and exploitation and doing
media and that's just in the US
I'm saying what you're saying that Jim
Crow and everything is that's in the US
but you have the apartheid you have a
lot a lot a lot of other things going on
throughout the world so you got your
thing we got a thing yeah you know so
all this to say I think a bit of
demystify in regards to why things are
in the place that they are like I drew
the paragraphs with black crime whatever
it is there's got to be a better
education regards to a lot of this stuff
not just we got six domains and you're
gonna think do you honestly believe that
Kyrie goes to this process and he's
changed his opinions you will put a
grown man in timeout you think you're
gonna change his mind no if anything his
fan base was bolstered even though he
may have lost endorsement deals in terms
of the actual ideas they've just grown
more popular and anti-jew sentiment is
increased so the strategy that they're
employing in order to fix the problem is
backfiring so more conversations are
needed in order to make things more
Saint not this [ __ ] where you go like
get rid of his brand deals but we'll
still sell the shoes like our make sense
our people our people are going to be
our people are going to be like hey you
know what yeah Kyrie's not bad or
they're gonna be like wait wait a minute
was that thing you was posting about let
me see that yep let me see that [ __ ] yep
what's it about that's what's gonna
happen more than the opposite so like
the way you like when you're saying that
it's backfiring yeah I I sh I tend to
agree yeah I really tend to agree with
that it's my social blew up with like on
Twitter or whatever like you know I mean
yeah when I was hashtag the Jews it
wasn't exactly positive
I mean you know what I mean when they
were talking about Facebook it wasn't
exactly the greatest thing so when I'm
seeing this I'm like I think it's
backfire just my thoughts uh uh um
is it a couple of people a couple of
Jewish people that care or most Jewish
people don't like they're like man
that's not no they care the Jewish
Jewish people people are like genuinely
worried about the prospect of
anti-Semitism or because they understand
like that stuff May potentially lead to
another yeah cause right so yeah they're
actually worried okay
yeah yeah but anyways let us know what
you guys think